i'm here with the one and only shangela
one of my favorite people in the entire
world oh i love you
and hit it what's the last show you
binged how to get away with murder
because i watch it over and over and
over for once season one all the way to
the end and back why do you watch it
over and over again you know there's a
lot out there you could be you never
know i might have to get somebody out of
jail one time i had to argue a case
they'd be like we need a second chair
i'd be like i qualify i'm the next kim
kardashian you could represent me in
court any day you worked with lady gaga
in a star is born what's your favorite
gaga song oh my gosh mary the knight
underrated what's bradley cooper up
close one word to describe him gorgeous
hmm give me another word too deep voice
wow we got three words we got three what
time did you go to bed last night one
a.m
[Music]
why i'm a night person you know i've
i've spent a decade performing night
clubs and everything so i really feel
like i get my best energy my mind is
really moving at night when everything
in the world is quiet i understand you
need your your time worst injury
oh i broke a leg i broke the tibia and
the fibula on my right leg on stage in
new york performing in drag doing a
death drop nope nope nope yes i did
honey i have still have the titanium rod
you can't see through the hose but i
have a titanium rod and two screws in
the knee and two in the ankles steal to
this day
you know when they say death drop you
don't actually have to die
you do know that right the crowd was
living
did you finish the song i tried but then
they had to come through with the you
know they wanted to carry me off stage
and they came through with the gurney
and they had to roll me out to the dance
so it was halloween oh my god it's
almost my anniversary
halloween in new york city and there i
am on the gurney going hallelujah i'll
be back everybody keep dancing and see
now this is what they call a pro ladies
and gentlemen i'm so proud of you and
your success we're here is killing its
second season on hbo what's it like
sharing all those stories out in the
world it is a gift really because i was
one of those stories at one time in my
life and i feel it's so important for us
to be able to amplify the stories the
queer stories that deserve to be told to
these small towns across america there's
some fabulosity just waiting to be
plucked in small towns everywhere and
you're doing it i know you have a bunch
of stuff coming up we can't wait to see
you continue to source angela that's why
you are here that's why you're the best
of the best that's why you killed it on
drag race i love you you've always been
such a great supporter and friend thank
you thank you thank you
no more death drops for her
[Music]
you